ARENA TICKET AT 3 I DOT COM
THEY SEE AS AN OVER TO YOU.
>> ALRIGHT CAR ENTHUSIASTS
THIS EVENT IS FOR YOU LAPSE ON
OF THE LIGHTS TO BENEFIT
SPEEDWAY CHILDREN'S CHARITIES
IS TAKING PLACE NEXT FRIDAY AT D
LAS OEVEGAS S ITMOTOR SPEEDWAY
TO TELL US MORE IS PAUL AT
ANDERSON WITH SPEEDWAY
CHILDREN'S CHARITIES, WELCOME. N
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH, THANKS
FOR LETTING ME COME BACK ON
SELLING ITS SO EXCITED ABOUT
THIS EVENT NEXT FRIDAY. HOW
DOES THIS WORK IT ALL WORK,
YES, SO IT'S OUR LAPS FOR
CHARITY UNDER THE ON NEXT
IDAY AUGUST 26 FROM 08:00PM
TO 11:00PM PEOPLE LIKE
YOURSELF AND YOUR COLLEAGUES
HERE IN STUDIO AND THE WHOLE
COMMUNITY CAN BRING OUT THEIR
CARS THEIR TRUCKS, THEIR
MOTORCYCLES AND THEY GET TO
DRIVE THEIR OWN VEHICLE AROUND
THE SUPERSPEEDWAY I MEAN WE'RE
TALKING SUPER SPEEDWAY WHERE
NASCAR RACING ON TWICE YEAR
SEAGO 75 MILES PER HOUR. YOU
FOLLOW A PACE CAR. THERE'S
ABOUT 12 AT A TIME AND FOR ALL
THE PEOPLE SAYING WHY COULD GO
75 ON I 15 WELL GUESS WHAT
THIS WAY WHEN YOU GOT THAT
BANKING IT'SG  G G A G G G G G
LA
YEAR'S IT'S A TO
UGH ROAD
DRIVING A CAR
AROUND THERE. E.E.
>> HOW DOOWES SOWOMEONE TAKING
PICTURES CAN WE TAKE PHOTOS
OURSELOUVES OUTO GO PRO'S ON OU
CARS. YES, I
THINK EVERYBODY
HAS A GOPRO THESE YES, WE DO
VE A PHOTOGRAPHER'S
WHEN YOU
GET ON PIT ITROAD WE W ILL
DEFINITELYNI HANIVE YOUR PYYOOT
YOTAYOKEN WITH WIYOURWI CAWIR W
IT WILL BE UPLOADED OADN OUADR
WEBSITWEE TO GET A FR
EE DOWNLOAD
AFTER THE EVTEENT TEA COTEUPLET
LATER. R.R.R.R.R.
IDS
HAVE TO BE 6 6 AND OLDER TO BE
IN THE BACK SEAT YOU HAVE TO
BE 18 OR OLDER TO DRIVE, BUT
WHAT 70 IS THAT AS LONG AS YOU
HAVE SEAT BELTS IF YOU HAVE
SAY 60,000 YOUR CAR. YOU CAN
HAVE ALL 6 PEOPLE IN THERE
IT'S JUST ONE PRICE SO IT'S
$75 TO GO 5 LAPS WHICH IS
AMAZING AT YOUR LAST MEETING
AND THEN IT'S A $100 FOR V I P
IS TO GO 7 LAPS AND EACH LAP,
YOU KNOW, IT'S LAS VEGAS MOTOR
SPEEDWAY SO IT IS SO MUCH FUN
AND THEN THE LIGHTSLI ARE ON AN
WHEN IT COMES TO ACTUAL CAR
WHICH ROLE ON THAT ANY CAR CAN A
COME OUT DO WITH THE ROLE IN
AS LONG AS IT'S STREET LEGAL,
SO YOU'RE ABLE TO GET ON THE
HIGHWAY AND TAKE IT PRIVATE
DOWN THERE YOU CAN GET OVER
EXACTLY STREET LEGAL YOU GOT
YOUR LICENSE YOU CAN DO IT
LIKE I SAID IT'S A FUN FAMILY
EVENT SO IF YOU PAY A $100 TO
GO 7 LAPS. YOU CAN HAVE YOU
KNOW AS MANY PEOPLE IN THE CAR
AS OUR SEA 1000 THAT'S WHAT'S
GREAT AND ALL THE MONEY STAYS
LOCAL TO GO TO SPEEDWAY
CHILDREN'S CHARITIES AND WE
HELP THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS
OF KIDS IN NEED EVERY YEAR SO
THIS IS A GREAT WAY TO END
YOUR SUMMER AND I MEAN AGAIN
THIS WHERE ELSE CAN YOU DO
THIS IN THE WORLD HISTORY,
WHAT IT IS THAT YOU NEED
EXPERIENCE JUST BEING IN THE
CAR DRIVING AROUND THE
SPEEDWAY THERE AND EXPERIENCE
IT FROM THE TRACK IN TERMS
THAT THE BANK MENSA 2 STORIES
HIGH THOSE IT'S A PRETTY
INTENSE FEELING DRIVE AROUND
THAT RIGHT IS SUCH A THRILL
PEOPLE HAVE COME BACK YEAR
AFTER YEAR WERE SO GREAT, BUT
WE DO WANT TO JANUARY AS WELL
BUT THIS IS UNDER THE LIGHTS
ONCE THE YEAR UNDER THE
SPEEDWAY LIGHT IT DOES NOT GET
ANY BETTER THAN THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US AND I'LL
BE THERE NEXT FRIDAY NIGHT
BEEN A BLAST COLLAPSED UNDER
THE LIGHT IS HAPPENING NEXT
FRIDAY AUGUST 26 STARTING AT 8
O'CLOCK AT LAS VEGAS MOTOR
SPEEDW